[Applaudissements]
70 000 supporters une ambiance de folie
on se croirait en finale de la Ligue des
Champions mais non ce sont des images
d'un simple match de football américain
universitaire
sur le terrain numéro 91 le tour en jeu
Wilfried peiné défend les couleurs de
Virginia Tech
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'au début ça a été il te
regarde un peu voilà comme le français
il te lâche le petit frenchy tatati vous
savez jouer au foot en France je savais
pas que vous avez des clubs bla bla bla
bla bla bla
mais après quand tu commences à leur
montrer sur le terrain que tu es présent
là il se disent ok non c'est un joueur
Wilfried PNL le colosse un mètre 92 130
kg a grandi à tour passer par les
pionniers de Touraine il a ensuite
rejoint les Spartiates d'Amiens il
devient alors biche champion d'Europe
junior mais son ambition n'a pas de
limite il s'envole pour les USA et non
pas le Canada comme beaucoup joue deux
ans pour le collège STM dans le
Connecticut avant finalement d'atterrir
à la virginité
la fac est bien les environnements de
Game incroyable
donc franchement je suis pas je suis pas
à plat je suis en troisième année de
Business Administration et management
donc là normalement d'ici décembre
prochain je vais avoir mon diplôme donc
en France ça serait l'équivalent d'un
Bac + 4
donc franchement non franchement tout se
passe bien
son poste actuel poste de dite teckel
Tech 3 sur le front son but empêcher les
courses de l'adversaire et à les gêner
le quaterback
t'as pas le choix c'est un sport ou au
niveau sacrifice va falloir si tu es une
personne qui n'aime pas faire des
sacrifices que ça soit faut que tu
manges beaucoup faut que tu manges moins
faut que tu ailles à la salle faut pas
que tu ailles à la salle il faut
c'est pas une personne qui arrive à
faire des sacrifices dans ta vie c'est
vraiment ce sport là c'est vraiment pas
fait pour toi car c'est un sport qui
demande beaucoup mais en retour tu
gagnes très peu
et oui la saison est très courte de
septembre à novembre son rêve son
objectif ultime être drafté l'an
prochain en NFL un rêve accessible pour
pourquoi pas jouer un jour orals de Los
Angeles